à l'est le jeudi c'est l'écho et ses
éclairs famille bonsoir reparler de quoi
on va parler du bilan de la maison de
l'entreprise avec jean-luc numéro
bonjour je donc des directeurs de la
maison d'entreprises puisque ce midi
sans organiser la réunion plénière
annuelle donc on a pu voir ce qui
s'était passé de les douze derniers mois
est-ce que tout d'abord le bilan a été
positif
oui on peut considérer qu'il est positif
dans la mesure où les partenaires qui
composent la maison des entreprises
s'investissent toujours autant et croit
en cette initiative qui a été prise il
ya maintenant au pressing quinzaine
d'années donc quand ça on peut dire que
que l'idée en tout cas que l'outil est
toujours dans une logique positive après
sur l'activité en tant que tel
effectivement pourra peut-être discuter
des chiffres les dons est différent ici
par exemple 300 entreprises créées voilà
donc c'est effectivement le nombre que
nous nous avons évoqué dans le courant
de la matinée sachant que sur ses ti sur
ces 300 ont produit composé en fonction
du type d'entreprises plus ou moins
grandes mais globalement sous 50 a
effectivement on est quand même sur sur
une activité économique dynamique donc
pas de crise pas d'effets crise s'il a
fait de la crise effectivement il se
fait sentir mais amoindrie sans doute en
tous les cas pour un certain nombre
d'entreprises même s'il faut être
vigilant parce qu'on sait de toute façon
que par ricochet les entreprises locales
vont subir effectivement les difficultés
que des maisons mères notamment peuvent
avoir par ailleurs bon de noter par
exemple de 1680 rendez-vous personnel
cette année il y en avait trois mille
cent l'année dernière est-ce que ça
s'explique par la crise de finalement la
raison et de l'autre au niveau de la
création d'entreprise proprement dit
c'est vrai que on a sans doute une
baisse de de la demande
liée effectivement peut-être un certain
une certaine réflexion que souhaite
avoir les idées porteurs de projets
creuser davantage effectivement leurs
idées rechercher des financements avec
parfois un peu plus de difficultés mais
ce chiffre s'explique aussi par le fait
que nous avons essayé de mutualiser un
certain nombre de
d'activité et notamment par le biais de
mise en place de réunions d'information
d'ateliers pour globaliser et permettre
un collectif de bénéficier
d'informations et pas toujours passer
par du conseil individualisé
dernières données sur les 3 300
entreprises créées 50% sont des auto
entrepreneurs on a eu une chronique sur
l'auto entreprenariat il n'ya pas
longtemps est-ce que vous pensez que que
la réforme pourrait changer la donne
diminué du coup le nombre de créations
pour l'instant on est les estimations
sont difficilement quantifiables c'est
vrai que on parle notamment de réduire
la durée de vie des entrepreneurs pour
des raisons notamment de concurrence
alors il ya le pour et le contre c'est
assez difficile même si effectivement
les encore des discussions en cours je
pense que de toute façon ça devrait
ralentir cet élan mais même si déjà
depuis quelques mois on sent un certain
ralentissement au niveau de
l'auto-entrepreneur mail évident que si
la réforme passe sans doute qu'un
certain nombre de dirigeants
d'entreprise en tout cas du jeune
créateur qui passeront directement en
structure juridique beaucoup plus
classique sans passer forcément par le
statut d'auto-entrepreneur question
parce que conclure je vous avais sur 300
entreprises à 50% d'entre nous ait fait
un peu comme ça comme ça non non c'est
vrai un peu long mais je pense que vous
avez raison il faut distinguer
effectivement la partie auto
entrepreneurs de la partie entreprise
classique même si je trouve que cette
idée de l'auto entrepreneur est
intéressante mais plus vu sous un angle
de période et c'est peut-être parce
qu'effectivement c'est que de toute
façon on a 10 des chiffres d'affaires
qui sont limitées que si on se développe
une activité de économique peut-être au
travers de l'emploi il faut passer au
stade supérieur donc on est là bien
évidemment pour ranger la crème pour
encourager la création et le statut
d'auto entrepreneur en fait partie mais
aller au delà de cet encouragement aux
favoriser effectivement le développement
des entreprises pour qu'elles passent au
stade supérieur on comprend mieux un
petit geste alors
la maison d'entreprise c'est aussi un
réseau on s'en rend bien compte quand on
lorsqu'elle était ce midi donc du coup à
la réunion il y avait vraiment beaucoup
de partenaires autour de cette grande
table ronde c'est également ce que
souligné françois de ligne et qu'ils le
président de la commission économie à la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines je vous
propose donc d'écouter ses réactions
le premier point qui est très positif
déjà c'est la mobilisation des acteurs
économiques du territoire vous savez la
maison d'entreprise qui était un service
de la communauté d'agglomération c'est
aussi la fédération des énergies alors
dans les acteurs économiques on allait
les entreprises on allait également les
experts comptables on a les bancs on a
l'ensemble de ce qui pour le territoire
de 50 de saint-quentin-en-yvelines que
sont mobilisés
beaucoup de partenaires et donc du coup
beaucoup d'événements petite
rétrospective de l'année on va revenir
sur les grands moments il ya par exemple
le forum de la création d'entreprise
j'ai eu quelques modifications cette
année le dieu tout d'abord plus qu il
avait lieu au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui nous a
gentiment prêté son espace donc c'est un
endroit que nous avons jugé adapté pour
une trentaine de structures exposantes
et puis un public relativement important
puisque nous avons recensé environ 400
personnes et on sait que certains nombre
d'exposants notamment du coût du
financement ont eu dix suite à ces
contacts donc pour nous c'est important
effectivement d'abord effectivement
d'avoir une opération qui marque le coup
mais aussi de savoir que derrière il y
aura des retombées notamment sur le plan
économique
deuxième temps fort les assises de
l'emploi également oui qui se tiennent
en février dans le cadre de la semaine
de l'emploi de la formation donc les
assises sont
lier plutôt aux entreprises même
exclusivement aux entreprises puisque on
essaie de les mobiliser autour de
l'emploi dans le cadre d'une journée
forte on s'est vraiment relativement
compliqué de mobiliser les entreprises
sur les sujets nés à l'emploi donc à
nous d'essayer d'innover aussi et là
aussi on est toujours dans une logique
de partenariat et on fait intervenir un
certain nombre d'experts pour d'abord
diversifiée des sujets est vraiment
aussi mobiliser des entreprises pour
leur faire comprendre que l'emploi est
important mais c'est le savent et mettre
à disposition le maximum de moyens et
c'est le rôle bien évidemment de la
maison d'entreprise et puis également le
concours concours qui a lieu tous les
deux ans avec cette année sept lauréats
des deux lauréats dans diverses
catégories de l'économie sociale et
solidaire jusqu'à l'innovation en
passant par la prestation de services
donc de bolloré à qui on l'espère auront
une longue vie devant eux et pourront
peut-être pour certains concourir
puisque on avait deux catégories une
catégorie en tant que porteur de projet
est une catégorie en tant que jeune
entreprise et on est déjà vu des
lauréats porteurs de projets concourir
quelques années après en jeune
entreprise alors justement sur ce sujet
peut-être aborder la plateforme
initiative qui a été créé il ya quatre
ans je prends environ et elle a bien
évolué notamment vous proposer
maintenant des prêts de croissance voilà
jeu jusqu'à présent on limitait le champ
d'intervention de la plateforme
initiative saint-quentin-en-yvelines
trois premières années d'activité
récemment le conseil d'administration et
l'assemblée générale a validé
l'élargissement du champ d'action donc
on devrait pouvoir financer à très court
terme et maintenant les entreprises
quelle que soit leur leur durée de vie
et sur des montants de prêts qu'ils ont
globalement jusqu'à 50000 euros une
belle somme également celui dont on peut
être parler des perspectives du coup
pour pour le futur il y a des projets
bien sûr pour l'année prochaine par
exemple une convention je pense avec
la chambre avec la chaîne ligne était
notamment impudent dans l'esprit de ce
que nous avions fait récemment avec la
chambre de commerce l'idée c'est à la
fois de valoriser l'ensemble des actions
partenariales qui se sont développées
sur notre territoire mais aussi
d'amorcer un certain nombre de doutes id
id 2
de réflexion et notamment dans le cadre
cette convention avec la chambre de
métiers devrait prochainement être mise
en place une étude à la fois pour
reconnaître des plus précisément le
tissu artisanal de saint quentin en
yvelines parce qu'on sait que sur le
secteur de saint quentin nous recensons
environ 1000 entreprises artisanales ce
qu'on ne sait pas toujours d'ailleurs
donc à la fois pour avoir une vue plus
qualitative et quantitative de ce
secteur très particulier du paigc
allemand avec une réflexion sur le
l'immobilier liée au secteur artisanal
et tout ça se situant dans un contexte
collectif d'études que mène la
communauté d'agglomération actuellement
notamment dans le cadre de l'économie
résidentielle rapprochement avec ses
chambres et un rapprochement aussi avec
l'université de 55 avec l'université
effectivement et ça ça fait maintenant
quelques années que l'université
travaille avec nous et on souhaite
développer un certain nombre de
réflexions et de projets donc
effectivement il ya beaucoup d'idées a
développé avec avec l'université de
versailles saint quentin et un dernier
point journée l'entreprise qui serait
prévue vers mai juin 2014 c'est un
nouveau rendez vous où il fera qui a
lieu tous les deux ans et on le fait en
alternance notamment avec le forum de la
création d'entreprise donc c'est une
manifestation qui s'adresse
exclusivement aux dirigeants
d'entreprise et qui se ponctuer d'un
certain nombre d'animations de tables
rondes et de conférences il ya un an et
demi maintenant nous avions louis
schweitzer l'idée c'est vraiment de
faire intervenir également une
personnalité du monde économique le nom
alors le temps et nous n'avons pas
encore aujourd'hui il ya on espère
arriver à mobiliser
quelques importants même s'ils le
faisaient
amis là-bas
effectivement qu'on creuse un peu pour
trouver quelqu'un de pertinent pour le
territoire très bien merci beaucoup
merci